aturdidos agotados pero agradecidos de
estar vivos estos evacuados acaban de
llegar de la ciudad de kharkiv tras huir
de la violencia en el pueblo cercano de
rus carlos uma
estás bien perrito
deja de llorar dónde está tu mandado a
buscarlo soba ha estado en manos de
rusia desde marzo pero las fuerzas
ucranianas afirman que han recuperado el
pueblo los combates han provocado la
huida de muchos de sus habitantes no
imposible estábamos escondidos en el
sótano horrible el sótano temblaba por
las instituciones gritábamos llorábamos
y rezábamos adiós
puede que los evacuados se hayan
marchado pero los horrores de la guerra
aún resuenan la recuperación del pueblo
de rosca lo soba es parte del impulso de
los soldados ucranianos para expulsar a
las fuerzas de putin dejar que el
presidente volodymyr selenski saludo la
supuesta recaptura como una victoria de
sus fuerzas los casuals en marketing
audio la situación en la región de
jarquín es difícil pero nuestras tropas
y nuestros servicios de inteligencia han
obtenido un importante éxito táctico las
cicatrices de semanas de combate están
por todas partes en jarquín situada a
sólo 32 km de la frontera rusa la
segunda ciudad ucraniana ha sido víctima
de constantes bombardeos antes de la
guerra archiv tenía una población de
alrededor de 14 millones de personas más
de la mitad de ellos se han ido